le chaos à nouveau en plein coeur de la
capitale kirghize
face à face deux groupes de manifestants
s'affrontent dans la confusion
d'un côté les partisans de
l'ex-président almazbek atambaïev et de
l'autre ceux du nationaliste sadir
jafarov nommé premier ministre après
avoir été libéré de prison lundi dernier
ces affrontements sont survenus alors
que chacun des leaders avait organisé sa
propre manifestation pour réclamer le
départ du président soru by djembé kof
un événement qui a failli coûter la vie
à almazbek atambaïev l'ancien mentor
politique de l'actuel président kirghiz
a été visé par des tirs alors qu'ils se
trouvaient en voiture
la recrudescence de la violence a
conduit sort une belle jen bykov a
imposé d'état d'urgence dans la capitale
bichkek
notre devoir principal est maintenant
d'assurer la sécurité de tous les
citoyens et de rétablir l'ordre social
notre peuple ne devraient pas être
victimes de la politique comme nous le
voyons maintenant
outre les appels politique à l'action il
y à des appels à l'esprit deux factions
et à une division du peuple en deux
camps nous devons empêcher cela mais
cette déclaration ne devrait pas calmer
la colère des manifestants déterminés à
obtenir son départ du pouvoir
ce run by john bykov s'est dit prêt à
quitter son poste sous certaines
conditions
une démission qui pourrait intervenir
après la constitution d'un nouveau
gouvernement et le choix d'une date pour
de nouvelles élections
dimanche dernier le résultat des
législatives à plonger le kirghizstan
dans la crise des soupçons de fraude
massive pesant sur la victoire de deux
parties proches du président les
violences ont jusqu'à présent fait au
moins un mort et plus de mille blessés
dans le pays